[Music]
in today's original we will once again
talk about a mcu or rather sony movie
more precisely we're referring to the
upcoming spider-man 4 with tom holland
almost one month after the movie's
release we would like to introduce you
to the most important information and
assumptions about the events after
spider-man no way home and discuss the
most common theories about the story for
all of you who have not seen no way home
yet there is of course an imminent risk
of spoilers otherwise we hope you enjoy
our latest original
let's talk about the production first
for many fans it came as a surprise when
shortly after the release of no way home
marvel boss kevin feige and producer amy
pascal announced that a new trilogy with
tom holland was being planned in the
summer of 2019 this still appeared to be
completely out of the question since the
entire future of tom hall and spider-man
was at stake at the time and no one knew
what would happen next until the final
agreement between marvel and sony so
it's all the more pleasing that the
popular film series is now to be
expanded with several sequels according
to foggy they are currently in an early
phase of production in which disney and
sony are thinking about the future
storyline he explicitly stated that they
want to prevent a farewell drama like
the one in 2019 at all costs lead actor
tom holland also commented on a new
trilogy in the french tv show called the
joe albee he answered the host question
rather diplomatically he stated that
there were some very exciting things to
be discussed but that he didn't know
exactly what and that the outcome of
these talks had to be awaited as you can
see the responsible parties are not
really far advanced yet and you will
have to be patient in the coming months
regarding news about the story
next let's shed some light on the story
and especially the ending of spider-man
no way home to then form possible
theories from it after homecoming and
far from home no way home is the third
spider-man movie with tom holland the
plot follows on directly from its
forerunner and presents the superhero
and his entire entourage with a major
challenge as mysterio uncovered
spider-man's identity at the end of the
second part and is closed into the world
peter parker who is actually concerned
about his anonymity cannot cope at all
with the unexpected fame he's
particularly burdened by the
disadvantages that his friends and
family suffer because of him and so he
decides to ask his co-avenger doctor
strange for advice after a failed spell
the world is even more upside down than
before because now several universes
have emerged which in addition to all
the villains of the spidey films from
the 2000s and 2010s also brings the
respective spider-man of dumb hull and
toby maguire and andrew garfield
together during the epic finale it
becomes clear that doctor strange can no
longer control the many rifts in the
multiverse which is why peter makes the
decision to cast a second spell this
time really no one is supposed to
remember peter parker including strange
himself and of course spidey's family
and friends unlike the beginning of the
movie peter is now willing to sacrifice
all that to save the world from the
collapse of the multiverse in the end we
get to see peter being accepted into the
famous mit and visiting his aunt's grave
last but not least the friendly
neighborhood spider swings through the
urban canyons of new york in a homemade
suit and goes on another manhunt in the
mid-credits scene eddie brogan is
symbiote as seen sitting at a bar
they've been sent back to the original
world by strange spell though a small
part of the symbiote remains on the
counter
now turn our attention to the theories
about the upcoming spider-man 4. first
of all it's not clear yet which
direction the new trilogy will take but
it seems that all signs point to a new
start the whole world has forgotten that
peter parker's spider-man so far now
spidey is free to go on a manhunt
undisturbed and come to terms with what
has happened especially the loss of his
aunt may was very traumatic for him in
addition he must cope with the fact that
his friends do not recognize him anymore
when he finally visits mj and ned at the
end of nowhere home and sees how
wonderful and peaceful their lives are
without him he decides not to reveal his
identity however we cannot imagine that
the story of peter parker will be
completely revisited instead we will
probably see a torrent spider-man who
has to consider every time and knew how
to deal with the situation on the one
hand he may be the righteous superhero
but on the other hand peter parker is
still a human being and he definitely
wants his longtime friend ned and his
girlfriend mj back
first let's begin with a very gloomy
theory but one that is not entirely
impossible in one scene ned asks toby
maguire spider-man whether he also has a
best friend to which he replies that his
best friend harry turned into a villain
and ended up dying in his arms what
might have provided fans of the first
spiderman trilogy with a few harmless
laughs could on closer inspection
actually be a hint at the new trilogy
true that does later empathically tell
peter that he will never turn evil
however even if that doesn't really fit
to spider-man 4 we could still be in for
a surprise
in part 5 or 6. another clue to this is
the plot in the comics there ned was
originally a co-worker of peter's at the
daily bugle and is later manipulated by
a villain named hobgoblin into
eventually sacrificing himself for him
so figuratively speaking ned dies just
as harry did in the arms of his best
friend in spite of some clues to this
fate we cannot believe that the popular
supporting character would undergo such
a change all the more so since he is
peter's best friend and not his work
colleague as in the comics
many fans have been expecting miles
morales to appear in some form alongside
peter parker for a long time the two
sony video games about their respective
superheroes have already shown that this
works wonderfully and they do would
certainly look great on the big screen
as well for many the appearance of
live-action miles is the next logical
step after all the multiverse is already
being further expanded with doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
finally peter could hand over the reigns
to miles in part 506 and entrust his
protege with a day-to-day business in
new york city an indicator for this
could be a statement of tom holland from
last november at the time he said he
would be doing something wrong if he was
still playing the role of spider-man at
the age of 30. he would be depraving a
younger successor of the opportunity of
following his footsteps he also did not
rule out a female character either
however a continuation of the story of a
mouse is much more likely because it is
completely unclear what will happen to
him after spider-man and new universe
too
of course it's not quite clear yet who
will be the main villain of spider-man 4
but we already have an idea as already
mentioned we see eddie brock sitting at
a bar at the end of nowhere home leaving
a small part of his symbiote behind many
fans were very excited about the scene
after a reunion of spidey and venom-like
in spider-man 3 with toby maguire is the
great dream of moviegoers interestingly
artist thomas de crest recently
published a couple of concept images of
tom holland in a symbiote suit on
twitter the concept artist clarified
that this was not planned for no way
home but it could be an approach for
spider-man 4. for this to be realistic
the symbiote would have to somehow find
its way to new york city to its new host
in fact we assume that venom and
spider-man will meet soon but well that
will already be the case in spider-man 4
is still up in the air
our final theory concerns peter's
academic future he could be accepted at
the massachusetts institute of
technology or mit for short just like
mjnet this storyline would involve a
change of location because the world
famous university is not located in new
york but in boston almost 350 kilometers
away the mit is so interesting because
another upcoming mcu heroine also
studies there namely ironheart who in
turn is the dedicated successor of
ironman who died in avengers endgame not
only could a rather complicated
friendship develop between the two due
to peter's emotional connection to his
mentor tony stark but an appearance by
iron hot would also fit wonderfully into
the mcu time-wise the character of riri
williams as the superheroine's real name
is is getting her own series on disney
plus anyway and who knows maybe the
blood of the series will fit in
beautifully with an upcoming spider-man
4.
well that's it for today's original what
are your thoughts on our theories about
the upcoming spider-man 4. can you agree
with our assessment or do you have other
perhaps more unusual theories see you
next time
[Music]